je mobilise la cage thoracique de
blanche
[Musique]
plus la cage thoracique les côtes sont
souples mieux elle arrivera à respirer
[Musique]
le problème c'est la d'estrella détresse
respiratoire cette détresse respiratoire
peut peut malheureusement être être
fatale
on peut plus avoir de spontanéité c'est
à dire qu'il faut toujours tout
programme et donc on veut partir en
week-end on peut le programme et on se
dit mais si jamais elle encombre et si
jamais elle a besoin d'un kiné et bien
il faut pouvoir trouver
un kiné à ce moment là et ça c'est assez
anxiogène et puis aussi est ce qui est
difficile c'est de l'expliquer surtout
mon frère de blanche parce que c'est
très dur
alors pour le plus petit on a
l'impression qu'il comprend pas même on
y comprend beaucoup plus qui montre et
le grand effectivement il est très
touché
il nous dit nous demander c'est vrai
qu'ils allaient mourir
en fait on on était d'accepter qu'un
jour mon père me trouveront donc aucun
pardon quand il met un enfant de 1 an se
dit il faut jamais mettre dans la tête
que je peut la perdre donc ça c'est
toujours parce que après tu me permet
aussi d'apprécier la de se rendre compte
du prix de la vie
[Musique]
on aurait été pas à prendre un bébé
lambda on
elle boit des biberons d'eau d'aguiar il
en réalité donc tout le temps parce
qu'effectivement il ya un gros risque
déshydratation déshydratation chez des
bébés avec la mucoviscidose
enfin c'est aussi avec même on leur
donne beaucoup à voir avec nadia il est
parce qu on a toujours peur qu'ils sont
déshydratation ben il faut souvent les
changer parce que sont trempés en fait
ils font moins énormément qui est est
aussi effectivement ils ont des
problèmes de celles parfois du fait des
problèmes et de l'insuffisance concret
déjà un bébé on fait toujours attention
ce qui tombe pas malade on est deux fois
plus précautionneux avec un bébé mais un
bébé qu'est la mucoviscidose
on devient un peu tout est multiplié par
dix la plus important c'est bon
l'hygiène naturellement c'est à dire que
on redouble de précautions au niveau des
microbes que par exemple les frères et
soeurs peuvent ramener de l'école nous
mêmes on apprend à se laver les mains
come back home des médecins ont compté
trente secondes on jette un lot je ferme
l'eau parce que j'ai tellement c'est
assez longue on n'a pas l'impression
d'être en seconde 1 2 3 en avant 4 5 le
dos de la main les ongles je sais que
aujourd'hui pour les bébés on n'est plus
obligé stérilisés en revanche pour
l'ange effectivement elle a encore un an
et je series systématiquement aussi bien
tétine que vivons en fait j'avais
partout c'était j'ai sous toutes les
formes
la première année on se dit de tout la
manière un bébé ils marchent pas en fait
c'est un peu triste à dire mais je n'ai
un peu le parquet effectivement jeu
contrairement à ses frères je la mettais
pas par terre
un effet du 4 pattes non parce qu'il
fallait que je sois sûr avant que le sol
soit propre
autant les premiers on se dit c'est bien
elle marche assez bien il fait du quatre
pattes et moi je voudrais mais pourvu
qu'elle se mette pas samedi cas pas trop
rapidement au caire est là si je suis
contente parce que au moins je suis sûr
qu'elle va pas échapper des saletés à
droite à gauche sur la bible on était il
faut un peu rusé on met ça dans la main
comme ça et puis on va prendre
du gel et objectifs ça va être
effectivement il réussi à récolter
toutes les enzymes pancréatiques
on va coller comme ça hop on vous donne
des consignes en vous disant
voilà maintenant aujourd'hui outre les
enzymes pancréatiques le petit
médicaments vous vous avez il faut
enchaîner richir en selle
une alimentation puisque a perdu celle 1
en matière grasse pour lui permettent
aussi encore là de grossir
[Musique]
j'ai mari qui est là ma soeur qui
énormément là et qui m'aide énormément
qui nous permet effectivement parce
qu'elle aussi elle est d'un optimisme à
toute épreuve
désormais c'est sûr qu'ils trient je
suis certaine persuadé qu'on va trouver
la solution et elle se donne les moyens
pour récolter des fonds pour que la
recherche avance
on a déjà récolté en quelques mois pas
mal d'argent on va pouvoir peut-être
bientôt financer un programme de
recherche tout ça ça donne espoir et
oubliez moi j'ai hâte qu'on lance le
programme
et puis mon mari be bassila souffre sa
très propres et le premier programme qui
va nous donner la solution pour blanche
et qui je pense que l'on méritait si un
jour on trouve ben on va été j'aurais eu
la plus belle vie fait que n'importe qui